- Leslie n'a jamais accordé
autant d'attention au coût
de ce qu'elle met dans
son panier d'épicerie.
Elle et son mari sont
à la retrai, , leurs
revenus au beau fixe.
Cette nouvelle coopérative
alimentaire, dans la petite
ville de Sleaford, offre à
ses membres de se servir sur
les étalages sans trop se
préoccuper du prix des aliments.
Pour un peu plus de 7 $, ils
ont droit à 40 $ de nourriture
qui provient de dons.
Un désespoir auquel s'ajoute
maintenant le choc violent d'une
facture d'énergie qui va tripler
par rapport à l'an passé.
Un foyer dépensera en moyenne
5400 $ par année dès
le mois d'octobre.
Un fardeau qui étoufferajusqu'at
aisées, a prévenu le ministre
des Finances du pays.
Sa frustration est partagée par
de plus en plus de tvavailleurs.
En fait, c'est de la colère
qu'ils expriment.
Chaque semaine ou presque
amène son lot de mécontents
sur les piquets de grève.
Éboueurs, cheminots, employés
du métro de Londres, ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux à
demander un meilleur traitement
en arrêtant le travail.
(sifflet)
Les dockers du port de
Felixstowe n'étaientasas allés
en grève depuis 30 ans.
Même les avocats s'y mettent.
Ils ne défendront plus d'accusés
jusqu'à ce que leurs demandes
soient entendues.
Tous ces débrayages ont
un point commun : le recul
du pouvoir d'achat.
En juillet, l'inflation a
atteint 10,1 % en Grande-
Bretagne. Et elle pourrait
dépasser les 13 % en octobre,
voire 18 % en janvier, selon
des prédictions pessimistes.
C'est le niveau le plus élevé
unun pays du G7.
Depuis sa démission en juillet,
Boris Johnson assure un service
à minima, évitant les grandes
décisions.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Please welcome Rishiununak!
- Ils sont moins
de 200 000 membres.
Et ils représentent environ
0,3 % de la population
britannique. Csosont surtout
des hommes blancs et plus âgés,
à l'aise financièrement.
En choisissant leur nouveau
chef, les conservateurs
choisissent aussi le prochain
premier ministre pour l'ensemble
des 67 millions de Britanniques.
C'est entre Liz Truss,
ministre des Affaires
étrangères, positionnée
très à droite, et Rishi Sunak,
ancien ministre des Finances
démissionnaire du cabinet
de Boris Johnson que les
conservateurdodoivent trancher.
À moins d'une grosse surprise,
Liz Truss devrait l'emporter
facilement pour devenir la
troisième femme à gouverner
la Grande-Bretagne. Celle qui
a d'abord fait campagne contre
le Brexit, pour ensuite en
devenir une ardente défenseure,
a porté une promesse constante
qui rejoint le coeur des
électeurs conservateurs :
des baisses d'impôts et
pas de charité.
(cloche d'église)
Travailler fort, faire des
sacrifices : Ady et Susanne
Filmer ne sont pas contre.
Seulement, le jeune couple de
Boston n'a plus rien à donner.
Tous les deux sont préposés
aux bénéficiaires en santé.
Pendant la COVID, ils ont été
célébrés comme des héros
d'un système public au bord
du gouffre après des années
d'auérérité budgétaire.
Aujourd'hui, ils n'attendent
plus grand-chose d'un
gouvernement qui les a déçus.
"Keep calm and carry on" :
l'expression consacrée
est née dans les bureaux
de la propagande pendant
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Elle devait rassurer les
Anglais. Le "ça va bien aller"
d'une autre époque.
"Carry on", continuez,
ils n'ont guère d'autre choix.
Quant au "rester calme",
le ou la prochaine première
ministre de la Grande-Bretagne
devra composer avec
un peuple qui n'a plus
du tout les moyens de
son flegme légendaire.